Does ascites only occur in the abdomen?
No, but ascites will occur in the body cavities. So ascites will occur in the abdominal cavity and in the plural cavity, so in the lungs.
So really in the lungs, you can get ascites in the paracardial sac, but that gets very serious.
You don't typically get ascites in the paracardial sac from cancer though.
But you can get ascites in the paracardial sac from paracardial infection, and that can be deadly.
That's what was happening post with these COVID vaccines.
That's where people would just basically drop dead because they got fluid in the paracardial sac and it basically squashed the heart.
It wouldn't get me to do die. But so from cancer, you can get ascites in the lungs. You can get ascites in the abdominal cavity.
The best thing to do is to make sure if you do get ascites, fluid in the abdominal cavity or the lungs, your body can't drain that, but I tell you, you just feel 100 times better when you go get that drained.
Pressure on your lungs or pressure in your abdominal cavities from, you know, I've had people have five leaders of fluid taken off of it off the developmental cavity.
You imagine five leaders of fluid, what that's doing to squash your organs and fill your body up. It's just carrying that around. It's not good to get that drained can be really, really beneficial.